Africa was once populated by hundreds of
thousands of rhinoceroses Africa's
national parks have had to ramp up
security because more and more poachers
are heavily armed the fight against
poaching is turning into a war the
Rangers in South Africa's Kruger
National Park don't want to be
recognised out of concern for their
family's safety from years back Rangers
wish to focus more on environmental
stuff and and with time ADA seemed to
have been a switch of us being more
military in some in some ways like you
can see I'm carrying a rifle there are
often firefights between the Rangers and
illegal hunters if the park employees
managed to arrest vouchers out hunting
rhinos
they're often hauled before the
magistrate court at the parks cook who's
a camp it deals almost exclusively with
cases of poaching
most of the detained poachers are young
men they face decades in jail says state
prosecutor Anzhi Venter I destroy their
own lives I mean I get to go home after
10 or 20 or 30 years leaving the family
devastated with absolutely no income
because to the best of our knowledge the
crime bosses then don't don't worry
about the family the men many of whom
come from Mozambique receive about five
hundred dollars for a successful hunt
that's a lot for the impoverished people
here and it makes a huge temptation
often the men spend all the money on a
single weekend then they return to the
hunt killing rhinos until one day
they're finally caught around 400 of
them are tried in the court every year
lawyer Mike mañana often defends young
poachers
Niko's it was DITA
the a childís indicates whether they
deal a state can approach anyone looking
at the educational background and
they're visiting capacity they tell them
there's a lot of money there and tell
them about the risk involved so I would
say their victims are such victims or
perpetrators in any case they're small
criminals others are making the big
profits from the illegal wildlife trade
if the killing continues unchecked
elephants and rhinos may disappear from
the wild in Africa by the middle of the
century
the rhinos are wiped out and white
Spanish follow maybe elephant and then
one day there will be another order for
lions and then leopards and then someday
we'll be fighting each other for the
last pack that would be left in this
vast huge of lands which used to be
called Kruger and in my genius to come
if you come back here maybe in 30 years
and then you walk around this huge line
2 million actors and then you don't find
a single animal what would be like